i went to the great state of texas we're
at the southern border tonight thank you
for being with us
and we're with former president donald
trump and our conversation with him
continues in a few moments but first as
sarah carter
has been reporting night after night for
this show
about the crisis at our southern border
well biden's border crisis is not only
damaging to the country
but also presents what is a serious
danger
a perilous journey to those crossing and
trying to enter this country illegally
watch this just down this road uh
sheriff's deputies here in brooks
county along with a judge are recovering
a body of a migrant what they're saying
is that the dehydration the hot sun
the heat and as well as the elements
other elements
in fact a few of the bodies that have
been recovered out here have been tested
covered positive so they're dealing with
a lot out here and remember this is just
one county
anytime you recover seven bodies and
within
uh six days that's a high volume
and that's what we're experiencing now
that we we're testing for kovic we had
two that were positive
out of that group so you mean you know
very well that you have others
that are contaminated that are walking
through or made it through right
right because these are left behind
they've got the bodies in the back of
the truck with the wrap they're getting
ready to
smuggle them across for people that are
crossing in this heat
you know uh especially under this
extreme
weather conditions is that part of your
mission to
search and rescue of course and and
recovery
you know a lot often times what will
happen with the illegal immigrants is
[Music]
they get lost they're out there in the
elements with the south texas heat
they don't have water they get
dehydrated and that's when you start
seeing more of these fatalities that are
taking place in those specific areas
and right now in brooks county i believe
they've already encountered 49
deaths up until this year which is a lot
all right joining us now with more fox
news contributor investigative
journalist sarah carter sarah
you have you have interviewed kids that
are out there alone
uh you've talked to ranchers that
recover dead bodies this is not
uncommon what you're reporting no it's
no it's not sean it's not uncommon and
it's tragedy
if you think about it we have over 22
000 kids right now plus
being held in camps all across the
united states
that journey takes over a month they've
already found this year
over 202 bodies and those are the ones
that they've recovered
think about all the people they never
recover because either the elements take
them away
the animals the environment there's a
lot of
there's a lot of difficulty for our law
enforcement when they're trying to do
recovery operations
i want to put it to you this way in 2019
250 people were recovered
this year we're only halfway through the
year and it's over 202
so sean this is a very difficult time
this is a very perilous journey a lot of
children lose their lives even before
they make it to the border
and i can't imagine how many more lose
it and we don't know
that are here right now all right sara
carter thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else